WINSTON CHANG: All right.
Well, today we're going
to talk about making
a Wordle app or an app
like Wordle, I should say.
Basically, you type in a
word that's five letters
and then you hit Enter,
you click a button
and then it checks how many
of the letters in that word
are correct or are present
in the target word,
and then it prints
that out and then you
hit Enter in another word,
and you just keep going.
So that's a pretty simple--
that's a pretty simple thing.
So for our
Wordle app, our overall strategy is going to be to
first work on the
logic of the application and get that all working.
And then once that's
done, we will make it look pretty using some CSS
and a little bit of JavaScript,
and we'll do that in a later video in this series.
What you're seeing
here is the actual Shiny Wordle app at the end.
And this does take a little
bit of CSS and JavaScript work, but it can be done.
So you know the way that I look
to get started with problems
like these is to just start with
something really, really basic
and then build it up.
So there's some problems
where that's not really
the appropriate approach,
but for something like this,
I think that's the way to go.
So first, we'll
work on the logic,
and then later on, we can
work on making it look nice.
But the first thing
is to get the game
logic working properly.
All right.
So we've got our studio started.
And I also already
have my word list here.
So I won't go into the
depth about how to do that,
but it's there.
So let's start with by
making a simple Shiny app.
Library Shiny, the UI is--
let's start with a fluidPage.
And I'm just going to put
in a textInput for now.
All right.
So that's the thing
that-- how people interact
with it is they type in
text [? into ?] input,
textInput, call it, guess.
And actually, we won't
put a label on it.
And all right.
There's that.
And server function(input,
output.) And actually-- sorry.
The first thing I'll do is not
just have people typing input,
but I'll just have it
print out what they typed.
So we'll do a
verbatim text output.
Let's load up Shiny so we
can just auto-complete.
Great, textOutput,
call it, results.
Oh, and also, a little tip.
Would be placeholder
equals true.
OK.
So then that will just
make it so textOutput
is always visible.
Otherwise, when there's
no content in it,
it's not visible.
So it can be a
little bit surprising
if it sort of appears
out of nowhere
or disappears when
there's no content there.
OK.
So let's see it's your output
results and for right now
we're just going to have it echo
the text that these were types
in.
The text.
We'll do input$guess.
And then ShinyApp(ui, server).
OK.
So now RStudio
recognizes it's an app
and just for
convenience, this is
a little thing I wanted to show
up in the little Viewer panel
down here.
So I already have it set up that
way, and I'll click run app,
and here's my app.
Hello.
It shows Hello, there.
All right.
So that's the very
start of our Wordle app.
So right now, it's
a little bit--
every time I type anything,
it's going to show it down here.
But I only really wanted to
do something with the input
when I say I'm ready.
So I'm going to-- and I'm going
to do that by adding a button.
So I say actionButton,
and we'll call it Go.
And we'll label it Go.
And now we have this
renderText here.
There's actually a number
of ways we can do this,
but I'll show you one of
like the sort of relatively
new ways of doing it.
I can add it, I
can use bindEvent.
So if you're familiar with like
eventReactive or observeEvent,
you can have those things
run only when a particular--
when some other
reactive thing happens.
So like when a
button is clicked.
And so you can
actually bindEvent
with reactives and observers,
but you can also use it
with these vender functions.
So I can say
bindEvent(input$go).
OK.
So it will only update
this or execute this
and update the result text
when the Go button is pressed.
And I still haven't
figured out the best way
to do indentation for this.
It looks a little funny here.
And I'm using the
new R 4.1 style
pipe here since I'm running that
version of R. And I'll save it
and reload.
So I say, hello and nothing
should happen until I press Go.
Say goodbye, and get nothing
happens until I press Go.
And now-- and it's just
replacing the content
of this text output right now.
So now's a good time to start
doing something well with that.
OK, so let's see.
One thing that-- let's see.
How do we do this?
So in Wordle, all
of your guesses
are limited to words
that are five characters.
And actually on top of
that, they're actually
limited to words that are
in a particular word list,
but let's just start off by
limiting it to five characters
first, and then we'll make use
of the word list after that.
So let's see.
So we can take
input$guess and let's say,
if nchar(input$guess) is
not equal to five then--
well, I'll show the naive
way of doing it first
and then do something a
little bit more sophisticated.
And then-- so if it's
not five characters,
then we'll just return out
of this random text function
[INAUDIBLE] nothing
or actually maybe we
should return an empty string.
And if it is five
characters, then we move on
and I'll have it show this text.
So paste.
You entered input$guess.
All right, reload.
So I can say abc and if I click
on here, nothing should happen.
But if I say hello--
which is five characters,
they'll say you entered hello.
And if I say goodbye, which
is seven characters long,
well, it's not printing
out, "you entered goodbye,"
but it is just making
the result disappear.
So that's actually not
really what we want either.
And there is a function
in Shiny called
req like for short for require.
I mean, you can use
it to exit out of here
and not replace the previous
contents of this output.
So we can say, req(FALSE).
OK.
Actually normally if we just do
req.req(FALSE) and we do this.
So if I say hello,
goodbye, it will still
like-- it'll still clear this.
But what we need to say
is req(FALSE) cancelOutput
equals TRUE.
So cancelOutput means when
you hit this line of code,
don't modify any downstream
outputs that are from this.
And this actually
isn't an output itself.
But if these were like in
a reactive expression that
was consumed by an
output then that output
would also not change.
So I'll say, hello
again and goodbye.
And when I click
on this, now it's
not erasing the previous
contents of this render text.
Oh, great.
And now we can compare it to--
I guess we can compare
it to word list.
So at the top of this app,
let's say source(wordlist), OK.
And in this word, this is
actually two sets of words--
there's common words which are--
that's a list of like
2,500 words which
are relatively common.
Are the most common
2,500 words in English.
And then there's a
larger list of words that
are like all five-letter words.
The shorter list is ones that
are, I guess, the target words.
And the longer list
R is a set of words
that users can use to guess.
But some of them
are really obscure
and it would be
really, really hard
if those were the target words.
So oops, let's
source(wordlist.R).
And let's see.
Actually, let's
just run that, oops.
Good Let's put that there.
source(wordlist.R).
OK, we have words
common_5 and words all_5.
So those are the two
character vectors
we have that have--
contain all the words.
So right now, we just want to--
right now, we just
want to show--
right now, we just want
to move on from here
if the word that they
entered is an actual word
in the words_all list.
So we can say, if input$guess
is in words_all, I've actually--
sorry.
So we have processed there.
If it's not in or it's
all_5 then cancel output.
OK.
So let's run it.
And again, hello
should work but we
just type in some
random five characters,
that should have no effect.
OK.
So that's pretty good.
Now, we can actually start--
we can use a target word and
start processing people's
guesses for that target word.
Let's see.
So we can do it.
Well, we can do it inside
the server function.
If we select a random word
inside the server function,
that means that each time
somebody connects to this,
they'll get a different word.
And if we select a random word
outside of the server function,
then it will-- as long as
this app is running and you
don't restart or quit
the app or something--
I mean, close the
app from the R side,
then everyone will
get the same word.
I mean, let's do it that way.
So there's words_common_5.
So we can just say target
is sample words_common_5, 1.
I think that's the
right sample for--
Yep.
Just sample one of them.
So and actually, of
course, we can always
just run this at the counsel.
We've got stop the app first.
Yeah.
So that picks out
one word-- duchy.
That would be really hard.
Yet another thing you
could do is do like a--
set of random seed
based on the date.
I don't know.
You probably do like as integer.
You know, Sys.Date.
OK, so yeah.
So let's try this.
And then oops.
I guess we can print it out.
So for today, the
target word is gives.
And then if we run
this all again--
so let's say the app shuts down
or if you're running this on--
if you're running this on a
server where there's high load
and you want this to be served
up by multiple different R
processes, then you want
this to be repeatable.
So let's run this again and
again if we would run target.
It's still gives.
So anybody who connects
today would have that word.
And I guess that actually works.
Let's use that method for now.
OK, so yeah.
So today the target
word is gives
and we're just using that
by setting the random seed
using today's date.
All right.
So let's see here.
OK.
So now, we want to compare--
we want to do some sort
of comparison to say,
hey, is the word that
the person entered--
if they make it past
this part there, like,
how well does that match
up with the target word?
And that's something
where it sort of-- it
makes a lot of sense to put
that into its own function.
And I will do that.
Oh, I'll do that below
the server function.
So let's say-- let's see.
What should we call this?
Check_word function
and then we'll
say the target word and
the guess, all right?
So we want to say check is--
not just are these two words
the same, if it was that simple,
we wouldn't need to
make a function for it,
but in Wordle, we need
to know how many--
which of these
letters in the guess
is in the target word
in the correct location?
And which of those letters
are in the target word
and not in the correct location?
So those are two
things that we want
this function to figure out.
And so we're actually going
to want this to return--
I guess it could be a
character vector or a list
with like the status of
each character in the guess.
So for example, if--
so let's just-- let me
just sketch this out here.
So if the target is gives,
that stays the target word,
and the guess is--
OK, and if the guest
is aisle, then let's
go through each of
these letters here.
So what we want
to tell the user,
the feedback that
we want to give them
is that A is not in the target
word, I is in the target word
and it's in the
correct location.
S in the target word but
it's in the wrong location,
L is not in the target word
and E is in the target word,
but in the wrong location.
And in the real Wordle game,
it shows that with colors.
And for right now, what
we're going to do here
is we're just going to sort of
mark each letter from the guess
and we're going to return
some information about it.
So let's see.
Yes, so what we
want to do is, we
want to iterate over
each letter in the target
and guess words and
do a comparison.
So first thing to do is to--
well, should we do it this way?
Yeah.
So the first thing we can
do is split those words
into a character
vector of letters.
So if I say--
actually, let me say, let
me change this target.
OK.
This is just going to be
kind of a long barreling--
target_string and guess_string.
So we can say that the target--
this is going to be
a character vector.
We'll say, string split,
strsplit, target string.
And if I just give it
an empty string here,
it'll split it
every character up.
And so let's try this
real quick actually.
So you can just do
this in the council.
I want Just to try things out.
So if I say, string_split
gives an empty string,
that will return this--
well, it actually
returns a list that
contains a character vector
with the individual letters.
So what we want to
do then is extract
the first element of that list.
So let's hit that again.
And now this is what we want.
We want a character vector
with those letters, OK?
All right.
And the same thing
for the guess.
So let's copy that.
Guess, guess.
OK.
And then after this,
now we can iterate over
each of the letters
and compare them.
So actually, one more thing
that we should do ahead of time.
Make sure we should make
sure these words are
the same length just in case.
I mean, the logic in--
that we had up above
should make sure
that both words
are five letters,
but just in case we
want to, we should
check it here and throw an error
if they're not the same length.
So if nchar(target_string)
is not
equal to nchar(guess_string).
Let's say stop(target and
guess string must be the same
length).
OK.
So once we get
down here, we know
that the same length and then
we can iterate over the words.
All right.
So let's say for--
and we can do this
with a simple for loop.
There's other things you can do.
Like you could use
mapply, but in this case,
we can just use a for loop.
Let's say for i in
seq_along(target).
So that should be five.
That should be 1
through 5, actually.
We're going to do something.
[AUDIO OUT] each letter.
So let's say, if guess(i)
is equal to target(i),
then we're going
to do something.
And let's see.
We need to-- well,
if they're the same,
then we need to
sort of mark that
and we need to save
that somewhere.
So let's actually
create another place
to store this information.
So we'll call this result. And
we can say, character, vector.
Oh, and actually.
And we can pre-allocate
this character vector.
For these really small
things like performance
isn't really a big issue.
But if you're working
with larger data
then it can help to
pre-allocate vectors.
So I'll just do that now even
though, in practice, for this
it probably doesn't
actually matter.
But let's just say,
nchar(guess_string), OK.
So again, let's--
well, if I just--
we can run it over
here in the console
and just see what
that looks like.
So if I say, character(5),
it creates a character vector
with five empty strings in it.
Yeah.
So that lets us assign
things into there
without growing the
vector in a loop
because that can lead
to performance problems.
But again, probably
doesn't matter here.
So let's see.
So if the guess and the
target letters are the same
for particular position, then
let's say, result(i) is--
let's call it correct.
You can say, else if.
So let's see.
Yeah, if the guess and
the target are the same,
that's good.
That's correct, but
we also want to mark
if the guest letter
is in the target word
but in a different location.
So we can say, if guess(i) is
in target, then result(i) is--
let's say, in-word.
OK.
And if it's not, then we'll say,
result(i) is not in-word, OK.
So we're just going to
collect those results
and return it, results.
See, there we go.
There's the end of our function.
So I'm going to just hit
Command Enter to run this,
and then we can test it out.
So let's say, check_word gives--
that's the target and
aisle is our guess.
So let's go through this.
So the first one, A
is not in the target,
I is in the correct
position, S is in the word,
L is not in the target,
and E is in the target.
So let's-- OK, that's great.
Yeah, just-- to
me, it just feels
like this is the right size.
Like this is a function
that just does--
it's one thing, it tells me
whether each letter is correct
and I can build on top of that.
I can use that
information to see if--
to check if everything is--
if the entire word is correct.
So maybe, actually.
Maybe I should say, this
is compare_words, OK.
And then I can use
another function
that uses this and
then provides even
some more information, like
whether or not their guess
was correct.
So let's say-- let's make
another function called
check_words, OK?
And say-- it's going to
actually take the same inputs.
But what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to return a data
structure that has
a lot of useful
information in it.
So let's say-- actually,
do I want to do this?
Yeah, OK.
Let's do this.
OK, so I'm going to say--
OK, so compare_results using
some long variable names
is compare_words
of these things.
And then let's see.
If-- let's say,
all(compare_results) equals--
if they're all
correct, then we know
that then the person
has finished the game
or they've won, right?
So let's see.
I'll say, correct.
That's true.
So let's start with--
the default is correct,
it's false, yeah.
Let's do it this way.
And then we can
return a list where
the guess was guess_string,
this is the guess word.
The results for each letter is--
let's compare results.
And correct is correct, OK.
So you can again do
check_words gives add aisle.
So this is a list.
The guess was aisle and the
result for each comparison
is here and this is
not the correct order.
But if we were to check gives
against gives, yep, should be--
gives is here, the results
for each letter is here,
and correct is true.
And actually I'm going
to rename this to--
oh, I don't know results_guess.
OK, never mind.
That's-- actually, yeah.
I'm going to give another
field called letters.
And that's going to be these
letters from the guess split up
because that may
be useful later.
OK.
Oops, there's need
a comma there.
Oh, guess_string, OK.
All right.
So let's see.
That's the word.
Maybe I should call this
word, letters, results.
And it's correct, OK.
So this actually
may be more richer--
this might be more and richer
information than we actually
need later, but it doesn't hurt
to have that information now.
OK, so we've written our
function to compare these words
and let's see.
So we can say, you
entered-- well,
actually let's just take
this and check words(target,
input$guess).
Now, this is going
to return a list,
and the render text is probably
not really going to like that.
But what we can do
is do renderPrint.
Well, actually,
let's first let's
see what happens when we do it.
It's not going to--
probably not going to be great.
So again, we know the
target word is gives
and we're guessing aisle.
Yeah.
So it's trying to--
renderText is expecting
a string to be returned.
But we're returning a list
with a bunch of stuff in it.
So it doesn't like that.
But what we can do
instead is use renderPrint
and what renderPrint
will do is it'll
take this result as
if you printed out
the counsel like
here and then it'll
display all that information.
Oops, got to reload.
So aisle, Go.
All right.
And yep, so this
is the information
that we need and
let's say, gives--
that is the correct word,
correct, correct, correct,
correct.
OK, great.
So now we're doing sort of the
proper analysis on the word
but now we want to
print it in a nicer way.
So I think-- so one
way we can do it is--
for right now is we
can print it out with--
like this.
And I'll demonstrate.
Like putting brackets and
parentheses around the letters.
So if the target word--
if the user has
entered aisle, so a--
let's see.
Let's say a-- oops.
We can put-- if the
letter is correct,
we can put square
brackets around it.
And if it's in the word,
but in the wrong location,
we put parentheses.
Let's see in the L, it
doesn't have anything
and E would also
have parentheses.
So we can print it
out this way for now.
So that the user has some
information about which letters
are correct, all right.
So let's do that.
And again, this is-- we could
put it right in line here
in this renderPrint,
but this is also
a good place to make a
function, to do the formatting.
So let's say format_guess.
Yeah, format_guess.
This is check_words, equals
result. Or maybe format--
yeah, format_result.
So these are not
great function names.
Naming things is hard.
And when you're working
on something that's small,
you can sort of get
away with using--
just sort of moving quickly
and just picking a name
and going on from there.
But when you're
working on like much--
when you're working
on bigger projects,
it's more important to have
good names because if you don't,
then you get really confused.
But this is a small enough
thing that we can be
a little bit lazy about that.
OK, so I'll just define
the function here,
format_result, function.
This thing called result.
Actually, let me call it--
well, guess_data is a
little bit long, but g_data.
Or actually let's call it r.
So we want to--
for each letter here,
we want to to look at--
this correctness-- the
result. Well, Yeah. r$results.
Again, OK, these are bad names.
This is small enough that
we can hold it in our heads.
So we'll just iterate over
the letters and the result
here and put the proper
brackets or whatever around it.
So all right.
Let's do a for loop again
for i in seq_along(letters).
And we know that
letters and results
are the same length so we
have to do any checks there.
So let's see.
So if-- oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, that's right.
So if we can say,
if r$result(i).
Actually, this
should be r$letters.
OK.
If r$result(i) is correct--
we put parentheses there, then--
OK.
Let's make it--
OK, let's say this-- call
this out_string, oops.
So let's do out_string is--
OK, and we're
going to do paste0,
so in square brackets, result--
r$letters(i) and
then, close bracket.
Oh, and actually, we
need to append that
to the existing output string.
Otherwise, we're going
to override it each time.
So we actually need to do.
Here's your out_string and then
stick the stuff on the end.
And once again, I'm going to
say like this is not the fastest
way to do these things.
If you are making a string by
just appending stuff to it,
it actually-- in R it actually
would allocate new memory for--
it'll copy the whole string
to a new location memory
and then put more
pen stuff to it.
And that's not very
efficient, but for this
since we're dealing with
really small amounts of data,
it's totally fine and it's
simple and it's fast enough.
OK.
So if it's correct,
we do that else
if, let's copy and paste this.
If it's-- what we say?
in-word-- my else is messed up.
OK, if it's in-word, then
we'll do the same thing
but we'll put
parentheses around it.
And else, well, instead of
parentheses or brackets,
we'll just use spaces.
OK.
And then at the end, we'll
return out_string OK.
So here we have the
results, let's check words.
OK, when we want
renderText, not renderPrint.
Reload, so aisle-- wow,
that's perfect, all right?
And gives should be--
OK, they're all
correct there, great.
And hello.
Let's just try that one.
Great.